The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
is the equation
that we-- this inviscid
Burgers' equation, no viscosity,
is the one we've learned
about for-- shocks appear,
fans can appear and
I want to do more
today with exact solutions.
So today is a little
bit more analysis
than numerical solutions.
So while doing
something, sort of PDE
rather than numerical
PDE, well, it's
natural to include Burgers'
equation with viscosity.
So that's got the
extra term there.
And if I can, I would
like to say something
about two other important
equations, nonlinear.
One has a third derivative
on the right-hand side,
so it's a dispersion
rather than a diffusion.
And that equation is named
after Korteweg-de Vries,
KdV it's often called.
I'll just put that down;
KdV is the shorthand
for that equation.
And it comes up in water
waves, one-way water waves
actually, along a
shallow channel.
It was actually seen by somebody
riding along next to the wave
and the wave kept its shape.
And so this equation
has had a period
of great fame in some way.
It's nonlinear of
course, but it was
discovered that there was a
really clever way to solve it.
Actually, we will
solve these equations
even though they're nonlinear,
that won't be too hard.
The clever ideas that went
into solving that one,
I can describe a little
bit, but not in full detail.
And then we'll connect also to
Hamilton-Jacobi type equations,
which are very closely related
to this in one dimension
and in fact, they'll
come into it.
OK, so those are the
equations and then, next time,
will come a little more
about finite differences
for those equations and a
lot more about the level set
method, which is more
connected to Hamilton-Jacobi
and is quite a remarkable idea.
OK, so that's for next time.
This is for this time.
So what I have in mind for
this time is: to begin,
can we solve our equation
starting from a source,
starting from a delta
function, a point source?
What's the solution look like?
And I guess when I
thought about it,
I can see several ways
to get at the answer
and it's a very worth it example
to do this from a point source.
It has a natural
interest and then
it comes up in many other ways.
So how we going
to get the answer?
Well, I can do it in
terms of fans and shocks.
Let me just proceed
informally at first.
The delta function is
like a step up followed
by a step down.
Well, a very big step up and
an immediate step down, right?
So it's the extreme
case of-- and remember
that the step up--
for the step up,
you remember the
Riemann problem?
Going from a lower
to a higher one.
That's the case where the
characteristics separate, leave
an open space that has to
be filled in with a fan.
So I would expect the
solution to start with a fan
and then I'm imagining
that as the limit
of an initial
function like this.
So that's step up,
will start a fan going
and then this step down
will start a shock going.
Because here, I have u is zero
and here u is something big
and that drop down means that
the characteristics from here
will immediately overtake-- the
characteristics from the zero,
starting from zero, have
zero speed, in the xt-plane,
they're just going up.
The characteristics that
start because of this thing
are going to the right,
so I'll have a shock.
So I'm expecting a
fan and then a shock
based on the previous lectures.
OK, and I'm going to
figure out what fan it is
and what shock it is
and where the shock is.
Now what I have on here is an
exact formula for the solution.
You might say, why didn't
you tell me that before?
And I will plug
in the initial, it
comes from the initial function
and from a minimization process
and it's not obvious.
That's a funny way to describe
a function of x and t,
but of course it does.
x and t appear here,
y is the parameter
and I'm minimizing
with respect to y
and that will give us-- well, it
better give us the same answer.
So I'm taking this as an
important case, which gives us
a chance to review all the
pieces that came into the-- all
the rules that came into it.
We had the rules for a fan,
which was of the form x over t
if it started at zero.
We have the rules for a shock,
which was that the shock speed
should be the jump in f of
u-- which is u squared over 2
for Burgers'-- divided
by the jump in u.
And so that's a
difference of squares,
this is a difference
of first powers.
When I do that simple
division, it factors out
and I get a u_left
plus a u_right over 2,
the 2 coming from there,
and the difference
going into the difference
of squares gives me that.
OK, and then the other condition
was the entropy condition
that f prime-- remember,
this is f prime of u--
so f prime of u,
which is here, u.
So u_left should be
greater-- the shocks,
what's the rule on
the entropy condition?
That the characteristic
should run into the shock.
So coming from the left,
they should be faster.
We have some shock line--
it's increasing with a speed
s, which is d position
of the shock-- dx/dt,
and coming from the left, the
shocks should be going faster
and run into it.
Coming from the
right, the shocks--
the characteristics
should be slower
so that the shock
line catches them
and therefore, these
also run into the shock.
So this is f prime at u_right.
And remember here,
it's just u_left bigger
than the shock speed,
bigger than u_right.
Now I'm going to go
to the delta function
itself, which will
be cleaner and neater
than this steep square wave.
So we could pick any
of those as the key
to telling us-- this is what
I'm expecting for a solution.
Here is zero.
Here is x.
So I'm expecting that--
I guess I'll graph u.
u of x at some time t.
OK, so I'm graphing u
at some later time t.
OK, I'm expecting the solution
to be u equal zero here,
because it starts
at zero-- well,
I'm really-- now, when I point
to that figure, what I really
mean now is a delta function.
So this is infinitely
thin and infinitely tall.
So characteristics are going
to take off and well, who
can say-- you might think the
whole thing would break down
because the delta
function is in some sense,
infinite at that point.
But it doesn't.
You'll see that a very
sensible solution emerges here.
And it's a fan, so u
is x over t, I guess.
So u starts at zero-- yeah, let
me draw u at some later time t.
It's linear and
then it's a shock.
So this is what I
expect for the answer.
I expect u to be zero, x
over t up to some point,
up to the shock, up to--
x is the shock position,
and then after that
it has the value zero
because the initial
function hasn't changed,
hasn't got the message.
So this was after
x equal X of t.
That's what it should look like.
I'm proceeding here sort
of on the basis of what
we know about the solution.
And maybe I can just mention
that the text, the problems
at the end of the
section on conservation
laws in the Introduction
to Applied Math text
ask about a few other
initial functions.
For example, minus
the delta function.
Maybe we should think
through those questions.
Is the solution with minus the
delta function the negative
of this solution?
What do you think?
No.
This is a nonlinear
equation and that fact
shows up right away
in the possibility
that when you change the
sign of the initial function,
you don't just change
the sign of the solution.
And other things,
I could ask well,
suppose I have an
initial function
u_0 of x and I add 1 to it.
Does that add 1 to the
solution everywhere?
That's a question
to think about.
So these are sort
of questions that
are not finite differences,
but differential equations.
All that remains here is to
find the position of that shock.
I guess one way to do it-- OK,
I can think of several ways
to do it.
One way would be to use the
fact that the total mass is
conserved.
So the integral
of u at any time,
the integral of that
function from minus infinity
to infinity-- that's
the total mass--
has to agree with the initial
total mass, which is 1,
because the initial
density distribution was
that delta function
at the origin
and that we know
integrates to 1.
So one way to find this
position would be the fact
that the integral from zero to
the place that the fan ends--
that's a capital X-- of
x over t dx should be 1.
1 because it was initially 1.
So that's gives us capital X
squared over 2-- over 2t as 1.
In fact, I guess
I'm thinking now,
this approach
occurred to me sort of
as I was walking to class, I'm
thinking now that's unbeatable.
That tells us where
the shock position is,
capital X squared over
2t is 1, so capital X
is square root of 2t.
OK, we could take that
as a guess, if you like,
and verify that it obeys all
the nonlinear rules here.
Right now it just obeys the
fact that the total mass
is conserved, which is
like the minimal fact.
But of course, we've
built into this solution
an expectation of fan followed
by shock, which is now
what we really want to verify.
So I guess, what
should I check next?
I maybe should check
the shock speed.
Does this solution
with that shock
give me the correct shock speed?
OK, let me check that.
What's the shock
speed? s is the speed
of the shock, so it's the
derivative of square root of 2t
and what's that?
That's square root
of 2 t to the 1/2.
So that's square root
of 2 times t to the 1/2.
The derivative of t to the
1/2 is 1/2 t to the minus 1/2.
So it's 1 over
square root of 2t.
That's the shock speed for
this proposed solution.
If we decide that the shock
should be at that point.
Now what's supposed to happen?
What is it that I want to check?
I want to check that
the jump condition is
correct for this shock.
That if a shock speed is
that, so the question mark is,
is this-- so that's
the speed of the shock
as we're sort of conjecturing
it to be located.
And now the question is
whether that shock speed
agrees with u on the left
plus u on the right over 2.
So what do I have to check?
I have to check what is u
on the left of the shock
if this is my answer.
Well, the left of the
shock is the point when
x equals capital X. That's
where the shock happened,
so it's capital X over t.
Square root of 2t over t.
So the value of u square
root of 2t over t.
That's where the fan is.
That's this height and
that height is zero.
So it's the average
of this and zero.
So that's the jump condition.
So this is the jump
condition that we're
checking and is it right?
I hope so.
Otherwise we're in
mighty big trouble.
OK yes, I have the
same cancellation
of square root of 2
into 2 and t to the 1/2
leaves me with-- yes,
I'm left with that.
So yes.
Jump condition satisfied by
this conjectured solution.
What else?
Well, just having a shock
with the right speed
doesn't mean I've
got the right answer.
Doesn't mean I've
got the right answer,
can I just make that point
because it's easy to slip by.
Let me take an extreme
case where I compare.
So these comments
are going to be
to say that I really need to
check the entropy condition.
Because I could
have two problems.
One which started from initial
value minus 1 jumping to 1.
So that's a Riemann problem.
And the other which starts
from 1 and jumps to minus 1.
And I guess in both
cases, remember
that f of u, which
is u squared over 2,
is 1/2 on both sides of
that line x equals zero.
In other words,
could this solution
stay at minus 1 and this
solution stay at plus 1
and have a jump between them?
And same for this.
This solution could stay at
1, this could stay at minus 1
and have a jump.
And now of course,
in this case the jump
will be upwards
from minus 1 to 1.
In this case it'll be a
drop from 1 down to minus 1.
And I guess I think this one is
OK with the entropy condition
and this one is not OK.
Let me say again
what I'm meaning.
The fact that I've chosen
this simple example
with f of u equal u
squared so that 1 squared
and minus 1 squared
give me the same answer.
So the jump across this line
is zero, the speed of the shock
is zero, the jump
condition is OK.
So I'm saying that the jump
condition is OK for both.
And it's the right thing to
have the jump in this one,
but this is wrong.
There should be a
fan and I guess I've
forgotten how the fan will go.
We do have 1 here and we
do have minus 1 there,
but the value of u is connected
not by a jump at a point,
but by a fan that gets
us from there to there.
A fan is also known
as an expansion wave.
That's the right thing
to have for that problem.
All that is just
to say that I do
have to check the
entropy condition.
But I hope it's not going
to be too difficult.
So my entropy condition--
remember, for this special case
f prime is just u.
So I'm really just
checking, now,
u_L greater than the shock
speed, greater than u_R.
u_R is zero of course.
On this side of the
shock it's zero.
So the shock-- can you get that?
We're going to be OK on
the entropy condition.
The shock speed is greater than
zero and it's smaller than u_L.
Well, how is that?
Is this quantity,
the shock speed--
no, greater than--
is this shock speed--
so checking that entropy
condition means-- shall
I put it up here?
u_L bigger than-- so this was
the characteristic speeds,
the wave speeds on
the left of the shock.
They must run into the
shock, so they must
be going faster than the shock.
OK, so let me just do
this comparison. u_L
at the left of the shock, on the
left of the shock x is capital
X, which we decided was root 2t.
So this is root 2t over t.
That's u_left because
the shock starts
when x is equal to root 2t
and that's what u equals.
And the shock speed we
figured out here is 1 over.
Now, so the question
is, is this true?
1 over root 2t.
I guess I sure hope that it is.
And it is, of course.
If I multiply up by this, I
have 2t over t, which is just 2
is bigger than 1.
So the answer again, is yes.
So that completes checking that
our proposed solution of fan
then shock is OK.
But, now let me
come to this formula
because it's quite a
handy, useful formula.
And what I have here
is f of u divided by--
or f of x minus y divided by 2.
That something squared
over 2 divided by t.
Sorry, divided by t.
Well, what do I want to
say about that going on?
Well, first of all, if I do plug
in the delta function for u_0,
it gives the right answer.
I can easily do
this minimization.
What what do I get when I plug
in the delta function for u_0,
just to start on
trying this formula
to be sure it gives the same
answer that we just found?
So the integral of u of x
and zero, the integral of u
is a step function.
So this will be a step
function of 1 for y
greater than zero and
zero for y less than zero.
Minimization requires
a little patience
because a step function of y
is coming in here, y is there.
And the only way I would
know to do that minimum
would be the separate
the different cases
and do each one.
Each one would be simple.
I don't think we need to
take our time to do that.
It's going to give
the same answer
and the minimization
is actually carried out
in the applied math book.
But I would like to
say where it came from.
Where did this formula-- so
I'll go back to this formula.
As a general formula
for any starting value,
starting function.
And in some way
derive the formula.
Figure out where
did that come from?
It came from the
Burgers' equation
with-- so now I want to
speak about this guy--
the Burgers' equation
with viscosity.
It turns out that that
equation-- and this
is very important.
That equation has
an exact solution,
because I can change
variables and make it linear.
I can turn it into
the heat equation.
So that was a neat idea,
which two people noticed
at almost the same time.
That very satisfying
change of variables
will turn this, will get
rid of this nonlinearity
and turn it into
the heat equation.
So it's a nonlinear change
of variables of course,
but not that hard to
discover once you begin
to hope that there is one.
And then, once it's a heat
equation we know the solution.
The linear heat equation
we know how to solve.
So we solve it and then what?
Let the viscosity nu go to zero.
Watch what this solution
is doing as nu goes to zero
and it will-- of
course, it'll be
smooth for any
positive value of new.
The viscosity keeps
things smooth.
The shock appears in the limit.
Maybe I should say something
just physically about waves,
breaking waves.
If you look at waves
in water, they're
obeying a nonlinear wave
equation, more complicated
than ours, but nevertheless
the same features.
And a wave forms and as
all water skiers know,
surfers know-- surfers,
I guess, know it best.
The wave in time
begins to break.
Now, up to that
time the viscosity
is actually not so important.
But as it begins
to break there's
a terrific u_xx now at the
moments before breaking.
And that u_xx then, that
term produces viscosity.
I mean, there is
a viscosity there
and suddenly it's important.
And so the viscosity will
prevent-- even though it's
small, the viscosity
will prevent
the actual, complete break.
I mean, what actually happens
in that wave is, of course,
a very difficult thing.
The nonlinearity,
turbulence-- everything's
happening suddenly.
Not easy, but the main point
is that as in many problems,
a term that's small in the case
of smooth solutions, where u_xx
has a normal size and nu is very
small, so that term is small.
Suddenly, u_xx has a
giant size and that term
is important,
physically important.
So Burgers' inviscid
equation, this
is the case with-- inviscid
means nu equals zero.
So Burgers' equation
is dropping that term
and it does have a shock,
as we very well know.
What are the steps
that these two people
noticed that take
Burgers' equation
and turn it into
the heat equation?
Let me see if I can
remember the two steps.
So I'm starting with
Burgers' equation
and I want to make
it the heat equation.
OK, so a first step is to
introduce the integral of u.
Let me call that capital U of x.
So capital U of x
will be the integral.
So if I write it this way, I'm
going to change u to capital U.
So I'm introducing a
new variable capital
U. The linearity
won't disappear yet,
but it'll look a
little different.
So if I took this equation
and I look at its-- well,
let me just say,
what's the equation
going to look like
for capital U?
If I write it down, then
you'll see that it's right.
dU/dt plus-- instead of d by
dx it'll be 1/2 dU/dx squared
equals nu*U__xx.
I claim that that's Burgers'
equation written for capital
U. Do you see that?
Let me just see, well,
how do I get from there
to the equation with a
star, Burgers' equation?
I think I just take
the x derivative.
If I take the x
derivative of every term,
I'm taking the x derivative
of U, so that's a little u.
So I have d little
u dt, as I want.
If I'm taking the x
derivative of this term
I have little u_xx, as I want.
And if I take the x
derivative of this term
it'll produce that.
The x derivative,
the 2 will come here,
dU/dx will be the little u.
The x derivative of
that will be the u_x.
It's straightforward.
And so now I've got it in a
slightly different, but still
nonlinear form.
Still quadratic.
Now comes the nonlinear
change of variables.
I think it's u is
minus 2*nu log--
so that's the nonlinear part--
of the new unknown that I
finally want, which is w.
So that's an exponential
change of variable.
Capital U is matching log w,
so w is matching e to the minus
an exponential of u.
And I won't go
through the steps,
but when you introduce
that in this equation,
it turns into the heat equation.
Of course, the initial
function is different.
The initial w is different
from the initial u.
Well, in fact we could
see, at time zero--
so this was at all times.
I didn't write the t explicitly.
But at time zero,
what is w of zero?
I guess I just take
the exponential.
I put this over here and
take its exponential.
So w of x and zero will
be u of x and zero,
the starting value of u, divided
by minus 2*nu, all exponential.
This is the sort of expression,
e to the something divided
by-- with a minus
sign-- divided by 2*nu,
that we're going to meet.
We meet it in the
initial condition
and we meet it in the solution.
Well, actually we now
know the solution.
If we remember, what's the
solution to the heat equation?
So we have the heat equation.
There's a constant
in the heat equation,
so we just have to remember,
where does that constant go,
and that's actually worth doing.
And then we have to start it
from this initial condition.
Let me just write, over here,
the solution to the heat
equation.
So this board will
follow that board
and remember-- so do you
remember the solution
to the heat equation?
You remember, we know
the solution that
starts from a delta function,
that fundamental solution
is that e to the minus
whatever over 2t, is it?
Yeah.
So what is w of x and t?
Let's see.
So we have the heat equation.
There is a square root of
4*pi and now it's 4*pi*nu*t.
When nu was 1 we
didn't know that,
but now, essentially this nu,
I can change the time variable
to nu times t.
So everywhere I saw a t,
I now will see nu times t.
And then, do you remember
what went in here?
The initial value,
w of x and zero,
times the fundamental
solution, that bell curve
that is centered
at x, and grows--
so it's e to the minus-- do you
remember what it looked like?
I think there's an e
to the minus-- centered
at x, so it's x minus t
squared over-- was it 2?
Over 2t, it was, and
now there's a nu*t.
x minus-- oh, wait a minute.
I can't have x's.
Let me take w of s and zero,
e to the x minus s squared.
This is from minus
infinity to infinity.
And that, finally, is going
to give me w of x and t.
So I integrate ds.
It's actually good to go
back to and see something
that we derived
before but we haven't
thought about it for a while.
This is the fundamental solution
starting at the point s.
This is the amount
of initial function
there is at the point s.
And I integrate over all those
little starts of point sources.
I integrate over all the
sources, all the way from s
equal minus infinity
to infinity,
and I get that answer.
And now I know what
w of s and zero is.
That's what I just found.
This is e to the minus,
as we've just said,
capital U of x and zero--
U_0 I'll call it-- over 2*nu.
So for this, substitute this.
It's requiring patience, but
not genius I'd say, to do this.
Now the question is, what
happens as nu goes to zero
and that the thing that
makes this worth presenting.
What happens to
integrals like this?
I have an integral of
something and the exponentials
are both negative.
I've somehow an
integral like this.
I have the integral of some
e to the minus something--
I'll say B-- over nu ds.
Do you see that the B
involves the U_0 over 2?
Well, let me put a 2*nu.
This is really what I
have in this formula.
Well, divided by this thing, so
let me put that 1 over square
root outside.
And remember, my
question is, what
happens as nu goes to zero?
Do you have any idea--
I mean, it's a mess.
We do not want to
do this integration.
It's an exact formula, but
not one I want to deal with.
What I do want is to know what
happens as nu goes to zero.
And the main point is that nu is
showing up in the denominator.
We have some quantity
in the numerator,
what is that quantity?
That quantity is U_0 plus this
x minus x squared over 2*nu*t--
over t, because-- in
fact, if we're lucky,
this B is exactly this quantity.
This is exactly this bracket.
That's, I think, my B, if I
change letter from s to y.
If I'd been like
prepared in advance,
I wouldn't have
introduced y and s
because they're both
just dummy variables
and they should
have been the same.
You see that this
guy-- because, you
remember the change between
little u and capital U?
Capital U is just the integral.
So that's U_0.
And this is this x
minus y squared over 2t.
I'm not sure if I've
got a 2 somewhere lost,
but we won't worry about that.
The main point
that I want to make
is, how do you deal with
an integral like this?
Because this is like a major
topic in a more advanced course
on applied math, a more advanced
course on the analysis of
applied math, not the
numerical analysis.
What's happening as nu goes to
zero= Well, as nu goes to zero,
this thing is
getting very large.
e to the minus a
very large amount.
So it's as near nothing
as you can imagine.
e to the minus a
very negative amount.
But still, the total
is considered somehow,
and the question is, what's
the main leading term
in this quantity, and the
answer is, you look at the point
where B is a minimum.
If B at one point is 1, than we
have an e to the minus 1 over
2*nu.
And compared to e to
the minus 100 over 2*nu,
the e to the minus 1
over 2*nu is way bigger.
So that in the end,
the contribution all
comes from the point
where B is a minimum.
And that's what this formula
says we should look for.
And if you figure out
what that contribution is,
and taking into account the
fact that we do have a 4*pi*nu*t
here-- without this, the whole
thing would just be going
to zero as nu goes to zero; this
e to the minus very negative
stuff is zero.
But we have a nu here, so in the
end something nonzero emerges,
but it emerges totally at this
point where B is a minimum
and that's what this
formula has found.
This is the minimum value of b.
OK, I won't track down further.
Do I remember the right word?
Is it stationary phase?
Did anybody meet these words?
I'm speaking now about something
in the history of applied math.
Still, those tools
that were created
over the pre-computer
years are still
extremely valuable to
understand what's going on
and this is just
an illustration.
OK, that's my comments on the
limiting case of Burgers',
which is inviscid
Burgers', and we actually
used this form of the
equation as the first step
in linearization.
As I say, it's quite
a nice exercise, now,
to use this formula.
An explicit formula, which we,
last time, did not suspect.
We were tracking down-- we
knew the problem was nonlinear
and were tracking
down shocks and fans.
Here's a formula that just
plain gives us the answer.
So this gives us a shock
or a fan, whichever.
This has the right shock
speeds if there's a shock
and it has the right-- the
entropy condition is satisfied
because it was satisfied all
along as nu was going to zero.
OK, so now do I want to
make some final comments
on this Korteweg-de
Vries-- KdV-- equation.
I mean, that would be an
ideal numerical example.
In fact, its importance
was discovered numerically.
One could say that this
is one of the biggest
contributions of numerical
simulation to the theory
of nonlinear PDEs.
The discovery-- and it just came
out of the blue-- the discovery
that that particular
nonlinear equation was
what we might call integrable.
That there is some
twist that produce
linear equations whose
solution give the answer
to this nonlinear equation.
Maybe what I ought
to say is, first
to tell you what those
numerical experiments were like.
And people just like looked
at the answers and said,
can this be?
OK, what were they like?
So we could find--
without much work,
we could find solutions of the
form, of a traveling wave form.
So we could find solutions that
have the form some function
of x minus c*t.
If you plug that in, you
have then derivatives of f.
You have an ordinary
differential equation for f,
and you can actually
find shapes, waves that
travel following that equation.
So of course, what you
can't do is add two of them
together and still have a
solution because the equation
is not linear.
So everybody assumed, OK, people
had found these traveling waves
before and the
computer will-- if you
start with the right
initial condition,
the computer will
produce a traveling wave.
If you start with the
right initial condition,
the computer will show
two traveling waves
at different speeds.
This c will be different
from one wave to the other.
So what will happen
as time goes forward?
One wave will catch the other
one because it's going faster.
So the shapes of
each wave are known.
I think it's 1 over
hyperbolic cosine squared.
So we have one wave
going with a different c,
going faster than another wave.
We're computing along.
The fast wave catches the
slow wave and they interact.
Of course they interact because
the problem's nonlinear,
and you can't see what's
happening at the time
when the big one
catches the small one.
But you can keep computing.
And what happened was
that after this jumble
the fast wave emerged
with the same shape.
And the slow wave emerge
behind it with the same shape.
And there was some lag of
course, some delay moment,
which had been used
up in the jumble
as the one passed the other.
But they emerged
looking the same.
I mean, that's sort of
like a linear property.
Not exactly, because you
couldn't just add them,
it wasn't perfect, but
the shapes were perfect.
And that suggested that this
equation might have hidden
linearity that nobody noticed.
And then finally
that was discovered.
It was a search.
People found
conservation laws, it's
easy to show that
the integral of u
is conserved by this equation.
We've done that
a thousand times.
Then other integrals
are conserved
and if you just
like to do algebra,
a short list of conserved
quantities: integral of u,
integral of u squared and
a few others, not just
u cubed and u fourth, of course.
People were creating a list.
And then somebody saw how
to get an infinite number
of integrals.
So that was a suspicion that
the problem was integrable.
That if you could
find an infinite list
of conserved quantities,
conserved even
under this nonlinear
interaction term,
that somewhere
something was linear.
And then eventually, a
change of variables-- well,
more than a change of
variables, a total twist
was found to integrate it
and get an explicit answer.
That's more than I can
do, but I want to say,
of course, that
immediately set out
a mad search for other
nonlinear problems
that were in this sense
completely integrable.
And now, am I going to be able
to list some of the ones that
were discovered?
I think I can-- whoops--
not on that board.
So I'll just end with the
completely integrable nonlinear
equations.
And I don't know if
the list is complete;
the discovery of new ones
is like a major thing.
So we have Korteweg-de Vries.
That was this the first.
Then there was a nonlinear
Schrodinger equation.
And the solutions, I have to say
what the solutions are called.
Those waves that I
mentioned, which--
they're not quite
that bad-- are called
solitons, solitary waves.
And it was the interaction
of solitons and the fact
that they emerged
looking unchanged
that set off this horrific
effort to figure out
what was going on.
So I was going to write
nonlinear Schrodinger in here,
and without saying exactly
where the nonlinearity appears,
but you take
Schrodinger equation
and-- then oh, I'm
blanking out on other--
there are just a couple
more famous ones.
I'll put those
names into an e-mail
rather than stumble here.
OK, so that's a little
history, with no details,
of an incredibly special
class of nonlinear PDEs.
Well of course, the
Navier-Stokes equations
aren't on that list.
And we still don't
know, especially in 3D,
I guess that's one of the
million dollar Clay prizes,
is to know whether the
Navier-Stokes equations have
a solution for all time.
So that's one of these
seven famous prizes
of which one of the
seven, geometry analysis
prize, apparently that
problem has been solved.
So there are six to
go and one of them
is whether the Navier-Stokes
equations have solutions.
Actually, I'll just take one
more minute of your time.
Thank you.
People had, or somebody
had conjectured
some possible vortex
blow-up in which
maybe that was a case, that
was an example of nonexistence.
We could find a particular
initial function
that created such a
blow up in a small space
that the Navier-Stokes
equations couldn't be continued.
But big numerical experiments,
just reported in the last
weeks, show that that
particular example,
that somebody thought might
prove nonexistence after
a finite time, doesn't.
So it's back to the
drawing board, really.
I don't see how
numerically we're ever
going to see that it does exist,
but this numerical experiment
was sufficiently clear to say
that that particular phenomenon
that looked dangerous
didn't go wrong.
OK, so next time,
it's a little more
about numerical solutions
of these equations
and then about the
level set method.
And then, looking ahead,
we have a guest lecture
on financial mathematics,
the PDEs of financial math,
for everybody who wants to go
to New York and make a billion.
And then we're going
to very quickly
be in the second
part of the course,
on solving large linear systems.
OK, I'll see you Friday
then for level sets.
Good.
Thanks for your patience.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Of course I have.